the singularity well i mean that's just
something that
that we just don't understand it's a
singular point and that means the
curvature of the space time at this
point has gone infinite
and all the mass has collapsed to one
point
so it's a point literally a point with
this mass in there so it's got infinite
density you know density is mass per
unit volume well if it's got no volume
it's
it's it's an infinite density these
black holes that are defined are defined
in the sense of
using general relativity and this is
this wonderful
theory of einstein which explains how
matter and
and curvature of space time are
intricately linked together so you
really need some a quantum theory of
gravity to try to describe that so and
i'm sure that a quantum theory of
gravity will resolve the question of
what the singularity is at the center of
a black hole it's just that we don't
know what that is yet so that solution
as it stands is there classically
but when you include the world of
quantum mechanics where things gets can
get smeared out what isn't clear is
whether that singularity will remain or
maybe it will get smeared out will this
event horizon still be there so will
that what we think of as the black hole
still be there i it probably will what's
that area like between the event horizon
and
the singularity is it like a is that a
tumultuous place or or do you not know
you're in it like almost like the i have
a hurricane if you're heading into the
black hole
and if this is a big enough black hole
you actually don't even know you've
crossed this event horizon it it um in
fact the density of the
of the black hole around the event
horizon uh for a
really massive black hole is of order
water that of water
and so you just sort of pass through but
what but what begins to happen is you
you begin to experience the the
gravitational
attraction it begins as you get closer
and closer to the singularity
it gets bigger and bigger and so you
will begin to stretch
and you will you will begin to feel the
effects of the pull of the black hole
and for a for but on the other hand for
a solar mass black hole you know one
that we have ordered this the mass of
the sun
then the pull of gravity on the event
horizon is much stronger and you will
have already
been spaghettified by the time you you
cross the event you won't see the event
horizon there's not a there's no
signpost saying you know event horizon
no return but you will you will pass
through this you will have all already
be gone in terms of living by then but a
supermassive black hole you actually
won't even realize
it's the
the the pull is is far less and the
density of the matter is far less and
significant there than it would be in a
smaller black hole
right it's a good question okay so if
the black hole is big if there's a big
black hole like maybe the one at the
center of the milky way then you know
when it crosses the event horizon
well if forget firewalls for a second
but it went across the event horizon you
generally would expect nothing much to
happen because actually the
gravitational field is pretty weak out
there as you start to go deeper and
deeper into side beside this black hole
you might think that indeed does it does
it retain its status as a particle i
would say probably not because um
you know you're entering that regime
where even your theory of gravity is
breaking down well let's let's think how
an electron became an electron okay so
so where does the electron get its mass
from it gets its mass from from the
higgs particle from the higgs higgs
field actually more appropriately and
for that for it to get its mass from the
higgs field something has to happen
called spontaneous symmetry breaking a
symmetry has to be broken
now if you restore that symmetry and
that symmetry does get restored at high
energies then the electron loses its
mass
and you know you can't really talk about
eventually the electron just becomes
part of some greater thing
and that's what would happen is i think
as you approach the the black hole
singularity things would just symmetries
would be restored you would no longer be
able to describe matter in terms of what
we think of the low energy
matter dynamics you would have to
replace that by some high energy version
of it and eventually you'd have to
replace things ultimately by the full
quantum theory of gravity and and
everything i.e maybe string theory so
you're really talking about strings so
you would never even talk about another
you can't talk about electron very very
close to singularity you don't even have
a singularity really you've probably got
some sort of stringy type structure of
which that electron has now become part
and is itself some stringy excitation we
do not know
how to
use gravity and quantum mechanics
in regimes where
gravity is incredibly strong and quantum
mechanics is playing a big role we we
can use
our quantum theory
is really well understood in regimes
where gravity is not that strong
gravity is really well understood in
regimes where you don't need to worry
about quantum mechanics but we know both
have to exist we know we have to be able
to understand the world of the
macroscopic and the microscopic and
there are regimes where but these two co
clash
and the
black hole is a regime where you have
the world of the microscopic quantum
theory and the world of high strength
gravitational fields coming together and
a manifestation of this problem is this
information issue because it's defined
simply in terms of its mass its angular
momentum and its charge it's got is
what's known as no hair there's nothing
coming out to tell you what's big gone
in there
the world of quantum mechanics on the
other hand should also be able to
describe this process in the world of
quantum mechanics there is a what's
known as a wave function it's integral
to the world of quantum theory that we
can keep track of this wave function we
solve it by the schrodinger equation
knowing about this wave function tells
us about the probabilities of everything
we always expect probabilities to add to
one if they don't then it's about you
know something's wrong with our system
when you lose information it means that
this wave function no longer is
deterministic in the sense that you lose
that ability to have probabilities
adding up to one
something's gone wrong with your world
of quantum mechanics but we believe our
world of quantum mechanics so we have to
be able to reconcile this classical
picture of the black hole where the
information gets lost to this quantum
mechanical picture where we know the
information shouldn't get lost we need
to be able to retrieve it and in order
to do it you're having to match these
two together the very existence of black
holes and the singularity that you
seemed it looks like you have at the
center of them tells you that einstein's
theory is not a complete theory it's at
best an effective theory that needs to
be replaced by something else
when you start talking about you know
high energies strong gravitational
fields and so on and so forth it needs
to you need something else which is most
likely string theory i guess it's
believed that the centers of galaxies
have got these supermassive black holes
right up to billions of solar masses
which actually raises an interesting
question how did they form right how did
how did these have time to
i think this might be some cosmic
strings
involved but no one likes the idea i'm
just hoping they'll keep finding these
supermassive black holes earlier and
earlier and earlier and earlier till
eventually there's just not been enough
time for black holes to coalesce and you
need another seed
something like a super like a massive
cosmic string but anyway that's just my
own pet hope is it possible that as you
start reconciling quantum mechanics and
general relativity and understanding
black holes better that singularities
could come under threat and people might
think oh it's okay there is actually a
little bit of volume there yes
absolutely and i think the majority
i don't know about the majority but
a lot of people that think about
what will be the effect of quantum
mechanics is that that singularity which
again is a breakdown of your
demonstrates a breakdown of your field
equations the breakdown of your
mathematics that singularity will get
smoothed out
an example of a star or an object whose
gravity was so great that light couldn't
escape from it so basically what's being
hinted at here for the first time is a
black hole of the existence of bodies
under either of these circumstances we
could have no information from sight